20:16 was the hottest year on record and
2016 saw faster than ever increases in
carbon dioxide co2 in the atmosphere we
now have the greenhouse gas bulletin for
2016 it's a yearly report from the World
Meteorological Organization and it
debunks the common talking point which
is hey we can't possibly evaluate
long-term climate trends because we only
have temperature data for the last
hundred and twenty or so years the
counterpoint is we can use science to
determine co2 in the atmosphere for the
last 800,000 years and in 2016 the
levels of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere reached their highest point
in 800,000 years and a significant
portion of that increase has happened in
just the last 70 years now I don't
necessarily want to just talk about the
science here what I'm more interested in
is CNN's coverage of climate science CNN
did a report about the study I just
mentioned to you 2016 hottest year on
record 2016 most carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere in the last 800 years and in
that report
CNN simply did not consider the
possibility that climate change isn't
happening they didn't even cite the
points of view of climate science
deniers they sometimes call themselves
climate sceptics or climate realists
they have all sorts of names for
themselves I think that it's pop number
one it's possible this is something CNN
did just in this one report and they're
gonna go back to giving a voice to the
climate science deniers in other
segments but that's actually a big deal
because there is this ongoing discussion
as to how significantly should such a
minority opinion be represented if we
have a ninety seven to three imbalance
in scientists climate scientists who
believe humans are impacting the climate
and those who believe humans are not
impacting the client right if the RIT
climate if the ratio is 97 to 3 among
the scientists how much air time should
the climate science deniers be given in
the media should it be 3 percent of the
time should it be
50/50 as we so often see this
science deniers will say well listen CNN
is biased fake news because they're not
reporting on the other side
CNN may have decided and if they did
decide just that decide this it's the
right decision and they correctly
decided that there is no legitimate
other side worth mentioning anymore and
if you look at comments online the
deniers are saying this is political
fear-mongering it's fear-mongering to
say 2016 is the hottest year on record
2016 had the most co2 in the atmosphere
in 800,000 years it's not political
fear-mongering it's that the scientists
are scared it's not liberals trying to
scare you the data is objectively scary
and scientists are telling us that and
by the way how is 2017 looking in terms
of temperatures for all the years we
have on record not good as of two years
ago 27 I'm sorry as of two weeks ago
2017 was the second hottest year on
record we've basically had no fall in
Boston it's almost uh we're close to
winter at this point we're close to when
we sometimes start getting snow in
Boston and really cold temperatures and
up until even this week we had
temperatures of 70 degrees so something
is clearly very wrong and more than
likely depending on what happens in the
last two months of this year 2017 will
be either the second or third hottest
year ever but hey nothing to see here
we're gonna reinvigorate the coal
industry says our current administration
how is this deliberate blindness to
what's going on going to be viewed by
future generations if they're even
around to actually discuss it and I
would reference yesterday's bonus show
story about how we don't have to wait
for some point in the future to start
being able to identify deaths happening
as a result of climate change in what
we're doing to the planet it's happening
now it's happening now and we talked
about it on yesterday's bonus show